MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Hi, and
welcome to this video, where
we will show you all the new
exciting stuff we have added
to Google Play services 4.4.
And as you know by now,
Google Play services rocks.
This also means that when you
use Google Play services--
ah, morning coffee.
Let's get started
right away, shall we?
Here are the highlights
for version 4.4,
new activity
recognitions have been
added to the locations API.
Yay!
And for Google Android
Maps API, we've
got some extension to
indoor maps and-- shh.
That's right, shh.
It's a blockbuster thing, and
we'll save that bang for later.
We also got some new stuff
for the Play Games Services
and Wallets.
And we'll round it off by
presenting In-app's Promo
Ads for Mobile Apps.
But let's get right
to it, and start off
with Activity Recognitions
in the locations API.
As you hopefully
already know, it
has previously been
possible to detect
if the devices on a bicycle,
in a vehicle, if it's still,
if it's being
tilted, or on foot.
Well that's a lot to begin with.
Well we decided
to add some more,
and we are now happy to
introduce two more activities,
FEMALE SPEAKER:
Walking and running.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Thank you.
That's right.
We added walking and running
to the activity detectors.
But we thought now, why don't
we go a little bananas here
and try those things out.
So what am I doing now?
FEMALE SPEAKER: You are walking.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: That's right.
That's very, very good.
So what am I doing now?
FEMALE SPEAKER: You are running.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: That's right.
That's very, very good.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Keep running.
It is good for you.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: So
what am I doing now?
FEMALE SPEAKER: You
are riding a bike.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: That's right.
That's very, very good.
FEMALE SPEAKER: No.
Don't stop running.
You are very close
to Googleplex.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN:
Whew, let me tell you.
That was both
exhausting and fun,
and that was just a demo app.
Imagine what your
apps can do with that.
Now let's look at the Google
Maps Android API, starting off
with indoor maps
where you can select
a floor programmatically,
detect if a new building comes
into focus, and, of course,
also get the active building
and floor.
This is, for example,
the second floor
of D Gates at San
Francisco Airport.
All right, moving on to--
and ladies and gentlemen,
that's right, we've got a
big announcement to make.
Let's welcome Street Views to
the Google Maps Android API
with a round of applause.
MALE SPEAKER: Get back to work.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Yes, sir.
You can now embed street view
imagery into an activity,
enabling your users to explore
the world through panoramic 360
degrees views,
programmatically control
the zoom and orientation
of the street view camera,
and animate the
camera movements.
Wow, that's a major extension.
Imagine all that cool stuff and
what it can do to your apps.
Over to Play Game Services.
In the 4.3 release, we
introduced Game Gifts,
which allows you to
request gifts or wishes.
Now we have extended the
request with a new API
so you can select multiple
game gift recipients.
For games, this means
that more collaboration
and social engagement can
happen between your players.
Which brings us
to the Wallet API,
where we added Wallet Fragments
to the Instant Buy API.
Wallet Fragments makes
it extremely easy
to integrate the Buy with
Google button in your app.
Just configure these
fragments and add them.
And just for fun, let's
see how shopping can now
be done in 10 seconds.
The user logs on to an app using
Google Plus Sign-In, selects
a Google Adjustable
Bike to buy, using
Buying with Google to
complete the purchase
and get it shipped
to your home address.
Voila.
A bike in 10 seconds.
And wrapping it up with the
mobile ads, where we have
added in-app promo ads.
This is an API
available for publishers
to display in-app
promo ads, and it
enables users to
purchase directly,
advertise goods in the app.
With these extensions, users can
conveniently purchase products
that interest them,
and advertisers
can reach consumers, and
your app connects the dots.
A Win-win-win, in other words.
That's it for this
time, but stay
tuned because we've got
lots more coming up.
Now it's your turn to go out
there and create great apps.
And don't forget to
tell us all about it.
Oh!
FEMALE SPEAKER: You need
to be more careful when
you are climbing.